[Musique]
tu connais la jungle ça fait partie de
toi mais l'exploration ce n'est pas un
jeu si tu ne regardes pas où tu mets les
pieds
[Musique]
je vais bien dabou ce on a fait une
grande découverte dans une cité d'or en
tic par rabat un état mais rémois allons
prouver qu'elle existe et moi aussi je
suis désolé chérie tu ne viens pas quoi
vivre en ville est très content et des
jeunes de tournage comme diego c'est une
bonne chose
oui on va être invité à ces fêtes des
rave parties où il ya ce genre de musée
papapapa passé latence bref soit
prudente c'est ça le message cousin
diego était encore plus énergique que
quand tu étais petit dora on est au
lycée te fait pas remarquer
soit
[Musique]
est tranquille droit c'est quoi ça
vous venez de quelle école la jungle
voilà la liste de la chasse au trésor
mettez-vous par groupes de quatre
bonjour d'un mois tu va nous aider à
trouver tes parents et la cité d'or on
est ou pire que la jungle ici je vois
trois mercenaires armés regardez doha a
pris un couteau pour la visite au musée
savez moi si vous voulez rester en vie
[Musique]
je travaille avec des parents vous êtes
tous en danger
on va mourir ici au faut quand même pas
exagérer un objet beau ça ob bosse à la
bouche
elle tenait singes bah oui normal dès
maintenant vous avez
[Musique]
il faut que je continue quoi qu'il
arrive
cette fille et les démente
je crois qu'on est en sécurité en danger
[Musique]